[Music]
this is a interesting discussion
especially because we are all men but I
know that we have such diverse opinions
and we don't speak for yourself white
guys bro did you see that he said you
have some diverse opinions what are you
talking about looking we have a hi
mentality we don't have hi mentality
that the fans complain about I'll say
whatever you guys will say oh the fans
think yall hi I'll go anti I'll argue
all for
why do you think I looked at you I get
your ass all right you probably have
dumb opinions I'll fire y'all the only
reason why people are allowed to be the
only reason why people are allowed to be
liberal is because they're around white
guys if you try to do that [__] around
non-white guys you get [__] up yeah
you got beat up oh [__] you guys going
to beat me up nah dude after I work out
a bunch bro hey there's there's a check
behind it all box yeah liberalism only
exists in Western Nations cuz there's
freedom of spee speech and they can
challenge whatever right but you do you
try that [__] in [__] Asia or South a
I mean South America or anywhere you get
[__] up true I like how that first
part of that sentence I was like okay
I'm like watching Ben Shapiro and I was
like okay now it's
JK and that means welcome back to
another exciting episode of off the
Record where we're still going to
Applause for silent Mike over
here even though he's going to be the
anti so the appla is going to be short
this time it's like my first day in
kindergarten here's the question okay
cuz this has been a viral video that's
been going around this dude's
interviewing like women on the streets
of Japan and he's wondering if paying
for sex counts as cheating did you see
my comment in here oh I've been
commenting in these videos oh no I
didn't see you didn't see Joe's comment
no I didn't specif T of can you scroll
down it's okay it's okay um so yeah have
a picture of Joe's comment yeah yeah
yeah sure sure Ryan can you pull it up
all right so he interviews these women
and a lot of these women are saying that
it doesn't count as cheating so are we
talking about the uh transaction or we
talking about the whole ordeal like the
[__] so the basic question of does
paying for sex count as cheating yeah
over there they think that if you pay
for sex because it's just probably now
just considered masturbation but with
the human body you know there's no
emotional investment they don't think
that that's cheating that's what these
particular women said and it's obviously
is it common over there actually started
with him asking guys and then the guys
most of them were like nah it's not
cheating some of some of the guys were
like well it is cheating if like that's
not the agreement between you two which
is more the sensible one and then some
guys were like nah that's not cheating
right and then all the comments were
like ask the girls then ask the girls
and then the girls were like nah it's
not
cheating is prostitution or whatever
pain sex also common there's a lot of
cultural like context that is missing
here and I've been [__] going in the
com comments to explain to them why they
view it the way that they do but so many
people see things from like a American
lens I don't need cultural context
they're like what's wrong it's wrong
it's wrong it's wrong and I'm all like
okay you stupid son of a [__] like not
everyone has the same like Evangelical
background of how they view marriage and
what the contract monogamy anymore is
[__] rare and then so societ for the
longest time for the longest time in
Japan marriage was love in a marriage
wasn't necessary and there's hella like
stories about getting love outside of
marriage so like marriage is like you
[__] have a contract with this person
you have kids you're lucky if you guys
fall in love but at the same time that's
not the role here the role here is to
build a family is to be a good husband
be a good wife mesh two families even
business wise or who knows what's going
on but Falling in Love is a different
story and on top of that commoners were
allowed to have love
freely rich people like wealthy people
Dy Royal people all of them they had to
have arranged marriages so then there's
hella romance stories about like you
know um you know you know what do you
call it like women having to like oh I'm
I'm going to run away from this [__] and
then marry a commoner and then whatever
right they give up their title to be
with a commoners right cuz that's true
love or whatever but if you're a peasant
like lot of people make this argument
where they're like oh well you know love
it's because you know uh love is a a
privilege of the rich it's actually the
opposite love is a privilege of the poor
yeah because there was nothing on the
line no like peasants and people from
towns and whatever they were just like
oh I like this person I grew up with
this other farmer kid and then they
could [__] marry their next door
neighbor for love that's fine but like
the elite it was always a business thing
I don't think that's Western that don't
know that though because like Western
Europe was like that too back in the day
it's just new dumb people queens and
[__] right it's just new dumb people
that's how I think human history was but
for them it's more fresh but then the
other layer is sex work is that uh more
common over there or allow is it legal
We call we call it horn well they don't
view sex call five versus one I'm
feeling the hive M coming so I'm trying
to be you know I didn't say anything
they don't view sex talk yeah your eyes
are talking dude they don't view sex
with the same type of sinful taboo that
Americans that's Christian so I think
that's that's where it's missing in
context right because it's like adultery
and all these things the context of how
people view the violation of like of
marriage through adultery is different
by culture right so like for them it's
like the way that they view guys being
horny and wanting sex is not the same
way that a Christian Society would view
it a Christian Society would be like all
right that [__] is sinful you have to
stick with one person and you have urges
but you're not supposed to act upon them
we don't admit it yeah but that's that's
the actual Foundation of our law and you
need to scratch it our our our
foundation of the law of adultery is
that is even though you have the desires
you're supposed to like control yourself
right whereas over there which a real
gentleman would yeah but over there it's
like you have desires so if you want to
express it then you're it doesn't make
you a bad person you just [__] do it
yeah get Jered off
and so the get a massage so the debate
between babe I didn't know they were
going to jerk me off but I couldn't say
no I wanted to be polite too but the
actual straight up sexy so the debate
between so the debate about cheating is
now what's the agreement between husband
and wife not necessarily is having sex
outside of marriage cheating right
that's the debate cuz yeah certain
marriage going to strip club might be
cheating can you um read Joe's comment I
just scrolled for like 3 minutes and
couldn't [__] find it Michael's
watching me [__] at the bottom
there's probably thousands bom there's
so many comments did you do it on the
Instagram one of the YouTube cuz I've
been fighting on Instagram uh Tik Tok I
think is where it all started but I
might be wrong Tik Tok I might be wrong
but I've seen I've seen a [__] ton of on
tikk you're going to find it okay please
is is different this is happening in
Japan well it's their view like I know
no no I'm asking this is happening in
Japan this interview happened in Japan
and got viral and now you know people
talk I think the biggest one is is
culturally they view sex completely
different from Americans where like
Americans I think there's a huge taboo
and shame and weird like thing when it
comes to sex and in Japan like it's a
sin yeah we we can make jokes with our
parents about it openly and it's not
this weird like taboo behind it you'll
see kid cartoons like you know shinshan
oh yeah yeah there's like nudity like a
naked ass boy or whatever there's
[__] yeah there's like like there's
kids like [__] showing their dick and
painting elephants on it yeah so the
nudity thing there's public baths uh the
way that they they view nudity the way
that they view having sex there's
festivals around sex and and the dick
and all that there's no like the idea of
it being sinful and bad they don't have
the same so it's like hey if you need to
[__] you're [__] all I've seen is
Rush Hour 2 that's not Japanese you dumb
ass I know that's why I'm asking that's
why I'm asking is it is it is sex work
normal over that no it's China is sex
work legal there even well it depends on
the country so like yeah there there's
like red light districts in like a lot
of these countries totally Chinese even
Germany it's a low right the thing is
out the other Asians don't have the same
view of sex either just Japan yeah Japan
is very unique with their view of sex
cuz Germany I think has a straight
brothel I mean even it's legal there
it's legal there Nevada right it's legal
R 3 a French movie run Hour 3 is a fresh
movie yeah yeah yeah Russ 2 is Chinese
yeah it's legal it's legal in Germany in
China I think they're more prude when it
comes to lied to me mhm I think them but
like it's not easy to find them it's not
legal was it unanimous in the video
every single person saying that same
thing that it's not four girls that were
like highlighted in that video all said
the same thing I don't know if that's
like cutting people out or whatever yeah
they could have cut out like 70 other
chicks and unanimous in Japan everyone's
like yeah this isn't cheating cuz I
doubt that no this episode of off the
Record is brought to you by Factor
remember a few years ago I used to be
fat like I'm talking about like
230 30% body fat and you know how I got
there A lot of times I waited till I was
hungry to get meals so by that time when
you're starving and hangry you just want
to eat anything so I was eating all the
fast food fried stuff drive-throughs cuz
when you're not in the right state of
mine you're always picking the wrong
stuff which is why I love Factor meals
because it is a dietitian creat ated and
caloric conscious meals meaning you're
going to have these things shipped to
your house meal prepped right away
you're going to have all this food so
when you're hungry what do you do you
don't have to leave the house you can go
straight to your fridge or straight to
where you store your food at work and
you're going to have meals that are
extremely delicious that can fit any of
your goals they got Protein Plus they
got caloric smart they even got vegan
options and everything is designed by a
chef and then also calculated by a
dietitian to fit all your Fitness or
weight goals so don't get fat like me
cuz now the last couple years I've been
able to hone in my diet and stay lean
and that's all because of prepping your
meals and that's the important of it and
now Factor has an insane deal for all of
our listeners which is you guys head to
factor meals.com off thc50 and use code
off thee reccord 50 to get 50% off
that's code offe 50 at Factor meals.com
sloff thc50 to get 50% off I don't think
it's unanimous but Japan does have a
very unique perspective on uh sex
culture and also I think it's important
to clarify that Society in general for
like a lot of the Asian countries have a
different maleo female relationship like
out here in the west right we're like
like women are equal and stuff like that
so all power to you know like out in the
East it's not all like that there is a
more traditional sex can be viewed more
transactional too yeah yeah because of
that because like you know the male is
like you know our traditional
Breadwinner whatever the woman is like a
traditional whether it be like a
housewife or you know part they have a
Duty or responsibilities or whatever I
think that also can slightly affect the
way that sex culture is perceived as
well cuz even like here in like K toown
there's those clubs right you go hang
out with your boys and they could all
have you could all be wiped up or
whatever but there's chicks that come
with the club that'll come and sit with
you and keep you company and talk and
you're flirting and all that stuff we
call them domies yeah but but that's not
even really but that's not considered
cheating and it's just part of that
culture it's just oh cool instead of
just being a sausage fest let's have a
bunch of chicks coming hang they're not
selling you sex they're just selling
hang out I think afterwards there's
other things that could lead to that but
it's kind of escorting but it's like out
in the public though it's out in like
the ktvs like the the the karaoke bars
right you like go and pay for a karaoke
bar so you're sitting in a private room
and then at some specific hour or some
time a line of girls will come I need
the hour why are you saying some some
specific time a line of girls will come
a couple girls will come in there or
every now and then like one or two girls
will come knock and if you want them
great if you don't like they'll Usher
them on their way and the interesting
thing is a lot of them aren't even like
just Koreans nowadays A lot of them are
even like Europeans or Russians or
whatever it's just part of the Korean
club culture so they go in there and
then if you're like yeah damn I'm down
to come I'll give you another example so
like in the business world out there
right um let's say me and Anthony are
from two different compan ianes and I'm
his senior I'm older than him right and
I'm like he he's trying to make a sale
to me whatever so I'm like hey what's
fun to do out here and then he'll be
like there's this bar and he goes where
the [__] is at take me to a brothel and
he's going to be like I guess I have to
right and then when we go to the
brothel he's not going to be like I'm
married he goes no we're both going to
[__] you know why because that's what
they say I got something on you now and
you got something on me and now can do
business now you're this guy's Toyota
[__] I'm Honda he's showing you your
trust yeah and then it's like we got a
bond here cuz that's how we're going to
trust each other there's weird [__] up
business things like that I'm not saying
that it makes it okay but that's the
standard right that's what they say
right eping the elites yeah so so their
H their their wies would understand that
[__] they're like oh you did it for the
business was it for your pleasure
whatever okay [__] it it's not cheap I
did it for Sony I did it for Sony I did
it for yeah there's a lot of weird [__]
that goes down that just doesn't really
happen in the state but another thing
too happens in the stat I think it
happens in the states it's just way more
but yeah that's what I'm saying it's
more hush hush and would the wife be
okay with it proba not right and then
there's another thing too about um
[__] um God damn it I just lost my
train of thought yeah you [__] M it's
okay think I'm going to need another
example so you all five say no no no
it's not cheating no I know how your
mind works now oh okay I remember what
I'm going to say do not say jack [__]
okay so working in two different
companies American companies and
Japanese companies right what I've
noticed is they're way more [__] Open
men and women about cheating so people
watch that video and they think it's
like a chauvinistic Society where only
men are cheating that's not the case
women are [__] cheating too they're
just not like and they're laughing about
it it's just normal so like yeah
Americans cheat it's not like they don't
cheat but they're like you said more
hush hush right so they would openly
talk about going out there with their
side piece men and women laughing about
it and then so I was like oh [__] I
didn't grow up around these I grew up
around Christian conservative Japanese
people but these folks were just and it
was in multiple companies I worked for
three different Japanese companies so I
was like oh [__] all these guys are
[__] each other all day long and some
of them are like fluid they'll be like
[__] guys and girls and I'm like God
damn Japanese people are [__]
perverted is is a relationship more
economical like is that like the the jam
like it's like sort of just it's very
transactional yeah I think it's
transactional compared to us so it's not
so much like all of I think Americans
tell themselves a big lie when it comes
to relationships it it has to be the
story book romance every time whereas
them I think it's more like oh she wants
to [__] I want to [__] we're having fun
prac yeah and that's that that was it it
doesn't have to be more than that but
here we have the guilt of like the
relationship has to be a certain way or
else I feel bad for just wanting to have
sex with this person I'm just trying to
[__] this person it's not you yeah
what's the big deal my so I think it's
just a blanket question that can't be
applied same answer can't be applied
right in our society and culture it's
probably cheating you know what I'm
saying and in Japanese maybe it's more
fluid maybe it is too some people maybe
it's cheating but you get forgiveness
yeah so I think it's what Joe said in
the beginning where it depends on the
arrang that you have with your partner
that's all so in our in America it's
most likely the arrangement is assumed
that because your marriage and you're
bonded by love and trust and loyalty
then it's probably cheating considering
sex is also sinful as adultery yeah yeah
the default is monogamy yeah yeah so
that's why it's cheating but again in
other cultures or other countries if
that's not the same concept of marriage
or that's just not how Society views sex
then like I can't honestly sit here and
be like that's cheating it's like it
really [__] depends on how you see
[__] cuz cheating is always based on
rules I don't think I get it because um
unless you say it again like 10 more
times go ahead Joe I think the but the
modern way of how these people were
saying it in the video was like um I was
it was like it was more like um what did
that couple agree upon one and then two
if it was like an emotional transact
like if ites person asking the question
yeah or is it some white dude trying to
like no it was a Japanese guy that's a
good that's a good you know cuz they do
that [__] tekashi from Japan but he does
Street interviews in Japan and he just
asks them all these different cultural
questions he has good videos I like his
video I do for does prostitution count
as cheating one of the girls says it
does not I wouldn't like it if they have
feelings for the one but I don't care if
it's just for sex so like you know these
women are just saying I'd rather they go
to a prostitute than talk to random
these chicks are rad I got to go to
Japan let's say there the second layer
let's say the second layer is okay the
the transactional sex is not cheating
but like let's say like one of these
chicks their boyfriends or husbands or
whatever sees the same girl and [__] and
always [__] the same prostitute regular
then is there any uh I guess feelings of
jealousy or like I don't know there's
got to be good question even I just feel
like that's a little more natural human
cuz then cuz say it is transactional
it's just sex but if you keep going back
I'm going to assume there's more than
just sex if it's the exact same one like
all right they like depends on the
arrangement that you have with for sure
for sure whether it's cheating but no he
was just asking he was just saying if
they're jealous oh yeah cuz eventually
you're going to assume like oh they
probably like is it like eating out it's
like I'm going to Chick-fil-A every time
I like Chick-fil-A cuz if I go to
another barber I feel like get his
feelings hurt right for sure what's
wrong with me for sure cuz you have your
guy for sure Happ true for sure like I
was mind blown when I talked to like
Japanese from Japan and then they would
talk about cheating and all this stuff
with men and women to the point where it
was so normalized and I was just like
holy [__] most people are like in the
states they hide this [__] they don't
openly talk about it they're ashamed of
it it's not a joke it's kind of like
they're doing something naughty like bad
and dudes here though that talk like
that but it's all guys right they're
doing coed guys and girls so I was just
like holy [__] this is a world that I
don't even know I remember the first
time like kind of working in the big
Fitness realm and I'm yeah 18 19 20 21
I'm working with other strength coaches
or whatever in the game and they're 40s
and I know they're married I probably
even met their wives and they're talking
like that they kind of blew my brains
like [__] bro I still feel bad about it
they talk all dirty they talk you know
they talk broy [__]
yeah [__] yeah yeah yeah [__] feels
good puss pussy's
wet